hello and welcome to this video emm
Michelle I am yeah but Mikhail I hope
off okay own name so i guess i had the
same as earlier game is really not good
p6 let's see how he plays it white
centers pretty pretty good
check let's think for one moment down
taking first or yeah i think i'm taking
first and not a clear not totally clear
i had almost the same game i think it
was the same game same position a couple
of games before that Wow and five
okay let's take the ship c4 it's it's
simple but it's good and now queen bee
three yes to play something really we
had done like night be aid or give me
material
you
I know maybe I should have taken first
maybe that would have been more precise
even now okay it's probably not a big
deal mmm yeah it might have been more
precise if I would have taken first to
ensure that i actually get them pawn to
d5 ok but what now here I had would have
been more precise really would have been
better
24 and what happens here 97 that screen
c6 and I asked to go back I guess okay
that's a piece that's a piece now the
position was very bad but not as bad as
in black he stands I still made a pretty
big mistake yeah after c6 this is a
mistake I think it gives up on some part
of the advantage taking as much stronger
I have actually this yeah this is
winning this is winning just just yeah I
can take this right that's over I just
bend the d5 pawn for nothing well now
the position is just really bad in the
other game I had c6 but why does clearly
better here as well and i took an a4 or
Bishop a three it's just them yeah I
just is no good I can just take this
this this thing also yeah like okay
agent just take things the opening
variation is really not not great don't
here I don't know what you should do him
it's it's it's just a cat choice between
various evils this with d5 coming is
also not good it just the case where be
six is a normal-looking move that is in
fact a mistake
but let's I just wanted to quickly this
back in three rookie aid Roxy one that
looked kind of normal yeah now i was i
was thinking there be five maybe on yeah
that is I mean check while this is
better for white it's not winning or
anything he still has issues here with
this and he's weakened but it's not not
so so clear it would have been much
better to force his structure and while
Quincy sick is a tactic win because of
the hanging pieces but even if it wasn't
for that if it just like strategy let's
same here here this is a lot better
because this is such a big weakness it's
it's he has no convenient way to cover
this palm and K hear this there are
already technical wins it isn't yeah
it's not a position that you can just
look at in general terms it just winds
technically already okay thanks for
watching